oui
[Musique]
la visite officielle du premier ministre
justin trudeau et sa famille en inde
c'était il ya trois ans
une visite qui avait fait jaser à
l'époque le premier ministre trudeau a
dû défendre aujourd'hui la pertinence de
sa tournée d'une semaine en inde pour
plusieurs raisons entre autres les
costumes traditionnels
mais le premier ministre voulait aussi
faire passer un message économique dans
un cadre plus sobre il s'est adressé à
des gens d'affaires
comme ici à mumbai justin trudeau par le
notamment d'éducation
il souhaite voir augmenter le nombre
d'étudiants indiens au canada dans la
salle des gens d'affaires écoutes dont
cette femme carole mastantuono elle et
d'autres vont saisir cette opportunité
d'exploiter un marché très lucratif
l'éducation collégial privé en utilisant
des pratiques jugées douteuses par le
gouvernement du québec
le recrutement des étudiants étrangers
est devenue un enjeu important au québec
ces dernières années en 2020 il y avait
près de 65 mille étudiants
internationaux inscrits dans des
universités des cégeps et des collèges
privés
un nombre qui augmentait chaque année
jusqu'à l'arrivée de la pandémie depuis
longtemps vos coups viennent de france
de chine vie et du maroc
mais un détail nous surprend depuis
trois ans on constate au québec une
explosion du nombre de permis d'études
des livres à des indiens
il est désormais plus de permis d'études
délivrés à des indiens cas des français
ou des chinois
la grande majorité des étudiants indiens
présent au québec ne sont pas dans les
établissements publics comme les
universités mais dans des collèges
privés
ils suivent une formation d'environ 2 en
données en anglais contre environ 25000
dollars
une formation qui mène par exemple et
une attestation d'études collégiales
de notre côté nous avons vraiment vu ce
phénomène depuis je dirais 4 à 5 4 à 5
années
je voudrais que c'est vraiment passé de
2 tout au tout
claude marchand est propriétaire
notamment du collège lasalle à montréal
ils confirment cette tendance donc il y
a cinq ou six ans il n'y avait presque
aucun étudiant indien qui fréquentaient
collège lasalle montréal est vraiment
depuis quelques années un engouement
certain
mais pourquoi ces étudiants indiens
choisi style le québec une province
francophone alors que cette communauté
plutôt anglophone est déjà très présente
en ontario et en colombie britannique
nous avons appris que plusieurs
étudiants ne réside pas au québec
josé manuel peiné la ce a été enseignant
durant 25 ans il a mis fin à sa carrière
après avoir travaillé dans deux
établissements qui recrutent des
centaines d'étudiants en inde
à son grand étonnement des cours se
donnent et les vendredis samedis et
dimanches pour accommoder des étudiants
qui vivent et travaillent en ontario je
pense bien entendu qui devait
certainement travail et d'une certaine
façon du lundi au jeudi et on m'avait
clairement dit que les étudiants
commencer son voeu a quitté l'ontario
pousse à revenir au québec le jeudi soir
donc faire la route à partir de toronto
l'un des directeurs de ces collèges
privés qui a souhaité conserver son
anonymat car il n'a pas l'autorisation
de ses bâtons pour nous parler va dans
le même sens ils vont travailler comme
camionneur où ils vont travailler au
noir dans des petites entreprises et ils
vont venir étudier la fin de semaine et
on leur offre un horaire qui les
accommode dans ce sens là dans cette
vidéo un recruteur indien qui a des
ententes avec des collèges au québec
fait même la promotion de ces avantages
si ces étudiants indiens font le show du
québec c'est en fait pour une raison
bien précise
ces collèges leur offre une porte
d'entrée vers l'immigration la province
de québec est la seule au pays où on
peut obtenir ce permis de travail post
diplôme après avoir étudié 900 heures
dans un collège privé non subventionné
donc évidemment ici offre donc certains
entrepreneurs ont réussi à exploiter
d'une certaine façon on cherche à
attirer justement ces personnes là qui
peut être voudrez davantage et mme y
étudier toute affaire va faire partie
des joueurs qui ont créé le marché des
collèges primés ces dernières années à
montréal
qui sont ces entrepreneurs pendant
plusieurs mois avec notre collègue à la
recherche
nous avons enquêté sur ce marché en
forte croissance
on a découvert que la majorité des
étudiants indiens se retrouve dans une
poignée d'établissements dont ils sont
devenus la principale voire la seule
clientèle on a aussi constaté
que plusieurs dirigeants ont travaillé
pour la commission scolaire anglophone
lester b pearson il ya plusieurs années
il ya notamment l'homme d'affaires nevin
cole haan qui recrutait entre 2012 et
des étudiants étrangers pour le
département international de cette
commission scolaire qui était dirigée
par cette femme carole mastantuono ils
sont devenus très actifs dans ce réseau
des collèges privés non subventionnés en
mettant la main sur plusieurs collèges
et en signant des ententes de
recrutement avec des cégeps carole
mastantuono a par exemple ouvert le
collège m du canada et a fondé la firme
du recrutement rising phoenix
international avec ses deux enfants
naveen cole haan a quant à lui créé le
collège matrix à montréal nevin colonnes
et carole mastantuono ont pu développer
leurs affaires et recruter des milliers
d'étudiants indiens tout en étant dans
la mire de l'upac dès 2016 des enquêtes
sont ouvertes
ils sont alors soupçonné d'avoir mis en
place un stratagème frauduleux au sein
de la commission scolaire lester b
pearson qui a par la suite mis fin à
leur contrat début 2018 carole mme
ashton tuer nos était présente en inde
lors de la visite officielle du premier
ministre justin trudeau
c'est à partir de ce moment là que le
nombre d'étudiants indiens au québec a
connu une hausse spectaculaire à ses
côtés l'un de ses associés à l'époque
dur indoor bâti c'est le recruteur
indien qu'on a vu plus tôt
par courriel il nous a fait savoir qu'il
a rompu ses liens avec la firme de
carole mme ashton fait nos quelques mois
après leur entente en raison nous at il
dit d'une incompatibilité dans les
méthodes de fonctionnement cure in der
bâti et maintenant le président d'un
collège présents à montréal et à québec
il ya quelques semaines
l'upac a arrêté carole mastantuono et
naveen cole haan
ils sont accusés de fraude pour des
gestes posés au sein de la commission
scolaire lester b pearson des faux
documents auraient été utilisés par
certains individus qui verrait au sein
de commissions scolaires pour favoriser
ou accélérer de façon illégale le
traitement et l'obtention de permis pour
nous de soutien étranger
leur procès est à venir ils ont refusé
de commenter pour ce reportage
d'une manière générale le secteur privé
a visiblement flairé une bonne affaire
deux nouveaux collèges sont apparus dans
le marché de l'éducation près de 50
collèges privés non subventionnés ont
maintenant pignon sur rue au québec
contre 28 en 2015 de nouvelles firmes de
recrutement ont aussi vu le jour elle
exige une commission qui peut aller
jusqu'à 50% des droits de scolarité
c'est le jeu des agences de recrutement
de constamment demander plus c'est lars
eller modèle d'affaires 6 30 % de cette
somme est remise à l'aja combien
reste-t-il pour réinvestir dans
l'expérience éducative rêve clairement
c'est un business lucratif
donc on cherche à couper les frais et à
faire le plus d'argent possible
et ça vient se répercuter ici dans
l'éducation
cette course aux profits au détriment de
la qualité de l'enseignement a
d'ailleurs été déplorée par de multiples
sources
on parle par exemple de professeurs peu
qualifiés d'amande investissements dans
le matériel ou encore d'un nombre
toujours plus important d'indiens dans
les classes d'autres éléments troublants
nous on s'y étaient rapportés comme le
paiement en avance des frais de
scolarité ce qui est interdit au québec
ou encore le dépôt en liquide de
milliers de dollars
c'est très étrange et nous avons
interrogé la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur
danielle mccann son gouvernement a
décidé de lancer des enquêtes contre une
dizaine d'établissements des questions
de qualité d'enseignement les des
questions de disponibilité de
l'enseignement de la manière dont ces
étudiants sont recrutés
effectivement ça sent pas bon et
différentes options que nous avons mais
ça peut aller même jusqu'à la révocation
d'un permis si on voit qu'on pôle âge
n'est pas conforme à ses obligations
ça peut même aller jusqu'à une révision
de la loi sur l'enseignement privé
le rapport de ces enquêtes est attendu
au plus tard au début du printemps
différentes mesures pourrait ensuite
voir le jour d'ici la prochaine rentrée
scolaire
récemment on a appris que carole mastan
shiono n' avait une colonne se sont
retirés de la gestion des collèges et
des entreprises qui dirigeait ces
institutions nous on fait valoir
qu'elles respectent les règles qu'elles
prennent la situation très au sérieux et
qu'elles sont prêtes à collaborer avec
le gouvernement du québec
lors de son célèbre voyage justin
trudeau a bien vendu en inde l
immigration canada après la pause
le problème c'est que des passeurs ont
flairé la bonne affaire
on est en octobre 2015
un avion arrive d'inde avec à son bord
un homme de 28 ans et sa conjointe
devant les douaniers ou présente un faux
passeport et demande immédiatement la
cil 1 agents frontaliers nous raconte au
téléphone ce qu'il s'est passé
il nous a dit que sa vie était en danger
en inde mais ils n'avaient pas de
document qui permettait d'établir
formellement son identité
dans ces cas là la loi nous permet
d'arrêter et de détenir un individu pour
déterminer son identité
cet homme s'appelle bintou patel il est
immédiatement placé en détention
provisoire le temps pour les agents
d'immigration de pouvoir l'identifier
des agents fouillent ses deux téléphones
il s'y trouve alors des choses
surprenantes
au total plus de 150 photos de passeport
des photos de documents de voyage et
aussi des visas à partir de ce moment là
on a eu des doutes sur monsieur patel et
on l'a référée aux enquêtes criminelles
on pense alors qu'on est face à un
passeur une personne qui en facilite le
passage d'autres personnes bintou patel
plaide coupable à deux infractions à la
loi sur l'immigration et la protection
des réfugiés pour avoir organisé
l'entrée une légalement au canada de
citoyens indiens il est finalement
condamné en 2018 à six ans de prison et
dans son jugement le juge indique qu'il
a fait partie d'une organisation
criminelle sophistiqué est spécialisé
dans la production de documents de
voyage
un réseau qui visiblement a su profiter
de l'attrait du canada pour organiser
l'arrivée au québec de nombreux indiens
qui viennent y demander l'asile
[Musique]
depuis quelques années le nombre de
demandes d'asile est en forte hausse au
canada on en comptait plus de 60000 en
2019 et la moitié d'entre elles sont
faites au québec en 2017 et 2018 des
milliers de familles haïtiennes et
nigérianes sont arrivés par le ch maroc
sam en quête d'une meilleure vie au
canada
mais depuis peu une nouvelle tendance a
vu le jour qu'on est passé au québec de
300 à 5 mille demandeurs d'asile
provenant d'inde en quatre ans une
hausse qui a propulsé l'inde en tête du
classement des demandeurs d'asile par
pays de naissance
nous avons cherché à connaître l'intérêt
de ces familles les raisons de leur
arrivée au canada et les conditions qui
les ont poussés à quitter l'inde pour
mieux comprendre
nous avons discuté avec une prof de
français en inde évidemment la visite de
monsieur trudeau finalement ça souligné
un tout petit peu toute cette politique
canadienne et québécoise d'accueil
d'aller dans un an il y a eu au moins
trois fois des pubs même dans des
journaux des quotidiens dans la langue
régionale pour l'immigration au canada
donc oui on en parle facilement et tout
le monde sait que c'est plus accueillant
dans cette partie du monde
d'ailleurs peut-être cet intérêt pour le
canada a cependant son lot de
conséquences
durant nos recherches nous avons appris
des choses troublantes ce qu'on faisait
dans parc-extension général c'est que
les familles payent peut-être mais
peut-être 50 mail à à quelqu'un labaki
qui voulu obtenir le visa puis dans
kenza
visiteurs quand ils arrivent ici
d'amendé généralement anne-marie
bellemare et travailleuse sociale dans
le quartier de parc extension à montréal
depuis plusieurs années elle a constaté
une forte augmentation du nombre de
familles indiennes qui sont arrivés à
montréal en passant par des
intermédiaires en inde mois pour être
d'un millier de pièces plus de 20 ans
oui il ya des réseaux qui sont organisés
pour préparer les familles à venir ici
pied oui c'est sûr qu'elle en a revendu
rails puis ça coûte très très cher
dépendamment des dpi mois et quelques
autres travaillent dans la santé dans le
quartier de parc extension pense que il
y à une sorte de je sais pas quels mots
utiliser un masque ya eu un réseau de
passeurs qui sont experts à faire venir
des gens et qui souvent vont être des
demandeurs d'asile ce médecin montréal y
rencontrent chaque jour de nombreuses
familles indiennes
il se questionne sur les véritables
raisons qui amènent certains demandeurs
d'asile au québec
moi je suspecte il ya beaucoup de des
migrants économiques qui se présentent
comme des demandeurs d'asile ses doutes
et l'existence d'un réseau de passeurs
nous ont été confiées par plusieurs
organismes et experts que nous avons
interrogés
nous avons aussi rencontré cet homme ce
père de famille a quitté l'inde et
l'état du pendjab en janvier 2019
il ne veut pas être identifié car sa
demande d'asile est toujours en cours de
traitement
mais il nous confirme avoir fait at-elle
un intermédiaire je rencontrais des
difficultés et ronald
j'ai obtenu mon visa par le biais d'un
agent je lui ai donné de l'argent à peu
près 20 mille dollars
je possède un terrain gelé vendus afin
de rassembler cette somme d'argent
il ne veut pas nous en dire beaucoup
plus sur les raisons qui l'ont poussé à
quitter son pays sa vie aurait été en
danger mais il reconnaît que le choix du
québec n'était pas le sien
je ne savais rien à propos du canada la
junte avait laissé entendre que le
canada serait mieux pour nous sinon je
lui aurais demandé de me donner un visa
pour tout autre pays dans la mesure du
possible il m'a affirmé que ce serait
plus facile de nous délivrer un visa
pour le canada en échange de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de dollars s'est
passé à fournissent une trousse complète
à leurs clients indiens
on y retrouve des billets d'avion un
visa des contacts à montréal mais aussi
un scénario a répété devant les
douaniers ces histoires seraient souvent
les mêmes c'est ce que nous confiait
nation des services frontaliers
on connaît le modus operandi ils nous
disent qu'ils ont tué accidentellement
une vache qu'ils ont été pourchassés
qu'ils ont dû quitter leurs villages
il y a aussi des partisans ou des
opposants d'hommes politiques ou encore
on nous dit que des criminels sont venus
dans le village qu'ils ont voulu que je
vende la drogue j'ai refusé et je me
suis enfui mais une fois arrivé ici au
québec
tout ne se passe pas comme prévu pour
ces demandeurs d'asile on a les pressant
avec soi sans fait un peu floués dans le
sens que les gens qui ont préparé leur
voyage leur pote dit exactement comment
ça allait se passer ici plusieurs
disques pensais juste à obtenir les
papiers très facilement quelques mois
filles et ben c'est pas ça comme nous
l'expliqué marie bellemare ces familles
sont face à un vrai parcours du
combattant
surtout qu'elles sont parfois dû faire
un choix déchirant certaines familles
ont laissé un ou deux enfants en inde
c'est ce qu'il aurait été demandée par
des intermédiaires afin d'obtenir plus
facilement un visa pour le canada une
grasse on craint pourtant que quelqu'un
qui veut venir ici car une mini stade ne
repartent pas évidemment d'asile ou
autre chose
marco magie parente ça serait la
meilleure façon de s'assurer que je
revienne c'est d'ailleurs vous avez vos
enfants pays
ces familles pour attendre longtemps
avant peut-être de pouvoir faire venir
leurs enfants au canada avec
l'augmentation importante du nombre de
dossiers ces dernières années mais aussi
l'impact de la pandémie les délais
d'attentes pour ces demandeurs d'asile
ont explosé et au moment où on se parle
c'est plus de 2 qu'on doit attendre pour
recevoir cette convocation devant la
section protection des réfugiés prête
entendu alors à cela se sont ajoutées
les délais d'appel des lettres
contestation à l'approché des râles dont
il peut s'écouler dans certains coop en
3 4 25 ans stéphane handfield est un
avocat spécialiste en immigration
il nous explique que ces longs délais
ont cependant un avantage pour ces
demandeurs d'asile pendant ce temps là
bien évidemment les gens la possibilité
de demander un permis de travail
renouveler ce permis de travail
envoyer de l'argent évidemment dans le
pays d'origine alors c'est sûr que pour
certains ça peut être dont avantage de
d'entreprendre cette procédure
le taux de refus des demandes d'asile
visons les indiens ces dernières années
est cependant parmi les plus élevés que
la moyenne générale et tourne autour de
50 % donc un sur deux pour les dossiers
indien sa tombe plus haut taux de 60
pour cent taux de rejet dont la
crédibilité est souvent mise en doute
dans ce dans ces cas-là on semble faire
des liens entre des histoires similaires
d'un demandeur d'asile à un autre ça
peut expliquer dans certains cas
justement ce taux de raisin portant des
histoires
ce traducteur qui est lié par un devoir
de confidentialité on a entendu des
centaines depuis plusieurs années des
mensonges aussi pour convaincre le
tribunal qu'ils délivrent ce statut de
réfugiés des demandeurs d'asile exagéré
volontairement ou quand vous êtes au
tribunal à la commission sur le statut
de réfugié vous savez donc que des gens
mentent en fait sur leur histoire
oui selon moi oui des fois oui
pour essayer de convaincre le juge
d'obtenir justement ce statut de réfugié
là oui mais c'est pas leur faute c'est
pour avoir une meilleure vie elles n'ont
pas le choix pour gagner votre cas votre
dossier
il faut dire ça pour rester ici
il faut mentir nous avons demandé une
réaction gouvernement de justin trudeau
le cabinet du ministre de l'immigration
mark oman et gino nous envoyer cette
déclaration le fait que quiconque de mon
un paiement pour les amener ou leur
permettre de rester au canada et
frauduleux le gouvernement canadien nous
a également indiqué avoir fait de la
publicité en inde pour alerter la
population locale contre de potentielles
fraude dans ce journal indien par
exemple cette pub
elle dit qu une demande pour un visa au
canada coûte moins de 100 dollars ne
gaspillez pas votre argent écrit le
gouvernement canadien
ils sont pourtant nombreux à voir
gaspiller leur argent
plusieurs familles menacées d'expulsion
devront bientôt retourner d'où elles
viennent avec des milliers de dollars en
main dans leur poche et un rêve qui
s'est finalement transformé en cauchemar
en étant d'été on a peut-être dans une
entame un sens puis la gloire la télé
l'heureux élu qui part au canada que tu
te fais serait déporté comme une vieille
chaussette analystes c'est vraiment
vraiment vraiment dur selon avec la
culture de bouc pc extrêmement mes
succès
[Musique]